i had to get to this
i had to get to this i've been meaning
to get to this for days
this is the burger king
pride advertisement
i don't know if you saw it
it says time to be proud and it's a
picture of two whoppers
but the whoppers one of the whoppers has
two top buns holding it together
and the other whopper has two bottom
buns holding it together do you get it
do you get it
so first of all the fact that we're
using these phrases top and bottom adds
a really graphic sexual component that i
don't want to think about when i'm
eating my processed beef at burger king
but
then even beyond that
you're seeing that the buns are not
complementary anymore instead they just
have two of the identical parts of the
bond and this is to say that it's really
good to be
lgbt lmnop whatever
the funny thing about this ad is that
the the ad
i think it sums up what a lot of people
think about the lgbt movement which is
look maybe it's not the worst thing in
the world if you were given that burger
you'd probably take it and say okay well
whatever it's a little little weird but
okay you'd but you would you would know
that something is a little wrong you
would know
that this is not the way the burger is
supposed to be
the advertisement i think is
undercutting the message that it wants
to send it reminds me of klm the dutch
airlines some years ago ran an ad during
pride month and it was these airplane
buckles and the the ribbon on the
buckles was rainbow and the ad said it
doesn't matter who you click with and
one of the
belt buckles had the male and the female
so it's actually how they're referred
right plugs are referred to as male and
female for a reason so it had the male
and the female and then the other one
was two males so just the parts that
you're supposed to click it but they
don't click in anywhere and then the
other one was two females same problem
they don't
they don't click in anywhere and the ad
undermined itself because
just by the logic of the airplane seat
belt advertisement
it does matter who you click with you
can actually you can only click with one
type of
seat belt component
totally under my the messaging is a
little bit
incoherent now
but it just shows you that there's no
logic to this movement there's no reason
to this movement that the reasoning
changes day by day it went from
bor were born this way and sex is
immutable and no one would ever choose
to be born this way to not only a sexual
desire changeable but actually sexual
sex itself is changeable i'm a boy but i
can actually be a woman it went from
the distinction between boys and girls
men and women is so essential that we
need to reorder our sexual ethics
then it became actually boys and girls
are basically the same and boys can be
girls and swim on the swim team and it's
no big deal
no coherence to it
at all
just a vague sense that huh maybe
something here is a little bit off
speaking of sexual ethics on the
heterosexual side nick cannon
who is an actor he
has become infamous in recent years for
making certain black nationalist
comments he's gotten a little more
politically active the other thing he's
really famous for now are infamous for
is having lots and lots of kids nick
cannon just announced his ninth kid
yesterday i think he's got two kids
being born this year by different women
he's got lots and lots of
baby mamas is it baby mamas or babies
mama sort of like attorney general or
attorney's attorneys general i don't
know anyway he's got lots and lots of
babies mama and he shows
no end in sight for for creating all of
these broken homes
he's already got seven kids out there
two more on the way probably many more
to come
the reason i bring up the nick cannon
story
is
obviously his behavior is disordered and
obviously it's selfish and it shows that
our sexual ethics problems in this
country
run a lot deeper than just lgbt which
everyone is talking about right now
there's a
far deeper rot that gets to the very
question of man's role not just in the
bedroom but man's role in society what
it means to be a man what it means to be
a woman like those africans that matt
talked to in his documentary it's it's
more than just dna it's more than just
your genitalia it's more than just your
chromosomes those tribals that matt
spoke to in kenya to be a woman is to do
the roles of a woman
to be a man is to fulfill the duty of
the man and there's great a great deal
of wisdom in that that we have duties
and obligations and a role in society
and we need to stand up and defend our
families and not just
you know bang any woman that meets
pardon my vulgarity
but the other reason i bring up nick
cannon here
is
for all of those sins for all of that
sexual confusion and immorality
at least he's not killing his kids
at least he's not killing his kids when
we think about
how everyone is obviously on nick
cannon's case here as as they rightly
should be
what he is doing is far far better
far i mean infinitely better than
abortion
which is an option available to him
which is something that's supported by
roughly half the country before that
half of the country goes after nick
cannon maybe they better take a look at
themselves
i'm so glad you liked that clip now
you've got to subscribe ring the bell
ding dong like whatever you got to do
make sure you get notifications for the
michael knowles show head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show boom click link
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]